you
hi everyone it's Jerry here's another
cool endgame study that I'd like to
share with you this one by a troitskiy
quite the tricky guy was this Troy etske
this is a name that may be familiar to
you this is not the first time I've been
not the first time I've shared a puzzle
by him in this cool chess puzzles
playlist it's white to move and this one
this puzzle interesting for a couple of
reasons just in and of itself the the
ideas in this one are interesting and
also when I put this up against my chest
engine stockfish six it was not able to
figure the answer out I gave it a couple
of minutes to crunch the numbers in well
at the end of the day it wasn't able to
figure it out only later did I realize
what the little issue was I encourage
you those of you trying to improve in
chess
these endgame studies are excellent
exercises to improve your calculation
skill try to unlock the ideas with this
one the look the little tricks or ideas
contained within endgame studies the
effort you put in is in my opinion time
well-spent so again it's white to move
in this one if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video spend some time in this
put it on one of your at-home boards
come back to the video at a later point
to see the answer white to move it's up
to you go ahead try and find the best
continuation okay the idea here is to
first play rook f5 if you got that as
the start great it's important to note
that black is ready to not only promote
but promote with check grabbing the
bishop right away we get a queen this
might be something to test out initially
and then see well can white somehow
generate some fortress
you know coordinate the rook pawn and
King in a way where black cannot make
progress unfortunately this is not the
case in some cases you may
be able to do that not here this will be
a win for black they will eventually be
able to win this pawn and then king and
queen versus king and rook is a win for
black additionally if white tries to
hunt down the pawn we just promote right
away and this one is actually much
simpler because after rook takes Bishop
we immediately pick up the rook so the
idea is to first give this check and
there's a couple ideas you now need to
see one is what to do if black goes to
the G file and the other what to do if
he goes to the e-file let's cover first
the G file and it doesn't really matter
which of the two squares it goes - let's
just say moves forward now we play King
h3 notice the king is now on the same
file as the pun this allows for a fork
tactic after black promotes well we're
threatening the pawn he needs to do
something so if blacks trying to win got
to push that pawn and if you get a queen
now we play rook g5 in regardless of how
the rook is captured bishop or queen
these are both cases of stalemate okay
so well what about rook well this is
with best play this is a theoretical
draw here this will not be enough to win
for black if you promote to a bishop
well that's not going to cut it to
Bishop same color Square and a knight
well this isn't going to work either
these are all cases of either a drawn
position or just a game over position
due to stalemate so those are the tricks
if the King goes to the G file having
this resource of rook g5 and let me
point out one other thing and this is
something that I thought about every
puzzle that I'm sharing with you and
this playlist is one that I try to work
through first of course one of the
things that ran through my mind and
maybe it's something that you can relate
to as well if you spend some time
working this from now it was at this
moment I questioned
was there a difference between playing
King h3 or rook g5 on move two and there
is rook g5 is not working because after
Bishop takes rook King h3 now black can
promote to not a queen at stalemate not
a rook stalemate not a bishop either but
rather a knight and this will be a win
these guys will eventually be able to
deliver checkmate so it's important just
a little move order detail we first play
King h3 wait to see what black promotes
to and only then play rook to g5 or
maybe not even rip to g5 again we wait
to see what black does King h3 is the
key
second move okay we got that covered we
know what to do if the King goes to the
G file suppose he goes to the e-file the
trick here is now played to the e-file
with check doesn't matter where the King
goes let's just say he approaches now we
play rook e1 preventing the pond from
promoting Bishop takes rook notice he's
defending h4 and so this allows now King
h3 and we have a similar scenario going
on you promote to a queen stalemate you
promote to a rook
it is stalemate you promote to a bishop
this is a dead drawn position and this
position right here is the reason for me
at least stockfish six the engine that
I'm using this is the reason that
stockfish six was not able to figure
this puzzle out for me it considers this
position here is winning for black but
that is not the case does not matter how
many dark square bishop you put on the
board you can't win this as black sell
for some reason and maybe it's something
you can relate to with your engine or
chess computer you're using it was some
for some reason evaluating this as a win
for black and that's why it didn't come
up with the
the correct continuation right from that
initial position this is a drawn
position if you're programmed promoting
to a bishop and the one last detail is
what to do if you promote to a knight in
the previous position I said that these
two will be able to force checkmate but
unfortunately they're a bit too close
together the white king is in check King
g2 attacks the knight bishop here to
defend we just take the bishop
the only other move is Knight to e2 and
now the final touch King to f1 and white
will be winning one of these two minor
pieces next and it's a drop so some
clever ideas of course it seems to
always be the case with this trade ski
guy we have to really see the two IDs in
mind if the King goes to the G file or
the e-file the stalemate in resources
and that last little trick where the two
minor pieces happen to be just a little
bit too close to each other and you're
able to hunt one of them down and it
turns out to be a draw in all cases
so as usual feel free to share any
feedback to this video on put it against
your computer see what kind of results
you get maybe you have a similar
experience feel free to share any
feedback in the comments section below
and as usual I hope you enjoyed it
that's all for now take care bye
you